[Musique]
les restaurants vont rouvrir
progressivement à partir du 19 mai et
jusqu'au 30 juin avec la levée des
restrictions sanitaires et pour parler
des préparatifs de la réouverture nous
sommes avec sébastien farge aux
dirigeants duo dan pâtit bonjour bonjour
enfanter
alors dans quel état d'esprit vous êtes
et comment où vous allez vous préparer
dans un bon état d'esprit sachant que
sur toute la vaccination avant donc je
pense que les échéances du ministre vont
être tenu comme ce qui s'est passé avant
donc je pense que là dessus on est on
est pas mal après on a quelques encore
négociations à faire au niveau de la
restauration au niveau des jauges de 50%
sur les terrasses qui reste un petit peu
un petit peu compliqué au niveau de sa
soit là et des terrasses soient grandes
ou pas c'est que 50 %
donc ça c'est encore en négociation vous
est fermée depuis le 30 octobre 2020
tout à fait enfin on est fermé pour la
peau la plupart des restaurants ils ont
dû fermer leurs portes nous on a
continué
à faire de la vente à emporter
principalement pour avoir une relation
vraiment avec la clientèle et puis
continuer dans une optique de jamais co2
jamais coupé puis gardé un tout petit
peu les salariés allaient mettre tout le
temps dans le dans le boulot et puis
surtout préparer des nouvelles choses
pour la reprise aussi alors comment ça
va se passer pour la réouverture vous
êtes déjà prêt on est déjà prêts comme
des dix comme on est restés ouverts tous
les
les fournisseurs tous les clients sont
restés un petit peu au contact donc pour
ça c'était peut-être un peu plus facile
que pour des restos conduit vraiment
fermer leur frigo ou les frigos sont
restés un minimum ouvert et que si on
peut dire si on peut dire ouverts mais
au moins ça il y avait un petit peu de
turnover donc si je pense que c'est plus
facile quand on a fait un petit peu de
travail avant pour ravoir contact avec
les tous les fournisseurs oui alors
justement vous avez une partie
restauration vous avez une partie aussi
bar pub
forcément vous attendez aussi l'euro qui
arrive en juin prochain les matches de
l'euro qui sont diffusées dans votre
établissement
est ce que vous comptez sur cette
période sur les événements sportifs pour
relancer aussi votre activité c'est sûr
que ça va aider vu que on a été arrêtée
pas mal de temps d'avoir un événement
comme le sport qui est conviviale et qui
va rassembler les gens c'est ça va être
quelque chose d'agréable par contre
après il va falloir va falloir faire
attention et garder comme on dit partout
les gestes barrières et ça c'est être
commencé quand on fait de la fête où
quand il ya des buts et c'est en voiture
que ça soit sur les terrains ou à côté
la plupart des gens sont assez convié
conviviaux et puis veulent se touchent
et il va falloir mettre le holà un peu
là-dessus coup alors que c'est ça le
plus compliqué on préparait déjà comment
ça va s'organiser dans son allée télé
qui sont à l'intérieur qui sont déjà
prêtes on met année un écran qui sera
dehors aussi donc ça nous on a
l'habitude ça fait des années qu'on
depuis 98 on est sur les événements
sportifs dont c'est quelque chose qu'on
qu'on sait qu'on sait faire donc après
avec les jauges ça sera un peu compliqué
au début de l'euro mais c'est vrai que
si les français volants jusqu'en finale
on sera quand même beaucoup plus
tranquille parce que normalement à
partir du 30 juin il n'y a plus de
jauger il ya que les gestes barrière
c'est à dire se serrer la main faire la
bise et c'est qu'ils vont rester en
vigueur quoi donc ouverture mercredi 19
mai du uniquement pour la terrasse
ensuite le 9 juin avec le restaurant
dans son intégralité
merci sébastien merci à vous dirigeants
diot dames patty et maintenant on va
aller à quelques mètres d'ici on va se
rendre à la ferme de voisins en 2020 ce
restaurant a perdu 35% de son chiffre
d'affaires pareil comme lausanne pâtit
il va pouvoir rouvrir sa terrasse le 19
mai rencontre avec romain gicquel le
chef de la ferme de voisins